dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly John I fail when
looking for illustrations for a
presentation most of the time I quickly
find an appropriate photo on the
Internet
however many of these photos are really
low resolution this often creates a
weird situation where I have to think
okay do I use the splotchy er lower
resolution image that gets the point
across or take a high-resolution crisp
image that is less educational in case
you are wondering I encountered this
problem for almost every single video I
make for this channel as you can surely
tell I am waiting for the day when super
resolution becomes mainstream super
resolution means that we have a low
resolution image that lacks details and
we feed it to a computer program which
hallucinates all the details onto it
creating a crisp high resolution image
this way I could take my highly relevant
but blurry image improve it and use it
in my videos as adding details to images
clearly requires a deep understanding of
what is shown in these images are
seasoned fellow scholars immediately
know that learning based algorithms will
be ideal for this task while we are
looking at some amazing results with
this new technique let's talk about the
two key differences that this method
introduces one it takes a fully
progressive approach which means that we
don't immediately produce the highest
resolution output we are looking for but
slowly leapfrog our way through
intermediate steps each of which is only
slightly higher resolution than the
input this means that the final output
is produced over several steps where
each problem is only a tiny bit harder
than the previous one this is often
referred to as curriculum learning and
it not only increases the quality of the
solution but is also easier to Train
solving each intermediate step is only a
little harder than the previous one it
is a bit like how students learn in
school first the students are shown some
easy introductory tasks to get a grasp
of a problem and slowly work their way
towards mastering a field by solving
problems that gradually increase in
difficulty
- now we can start playing with the
thought of using a generative
adversarial Network we talked a lot
about this architecture in this series
at this time I will only note that
training these is fraught with
difficulties so every bit of help we can
get is more than welcome
so the role of curriculum learning is to
help easing this process
note that this research field is well
explored and has a remarkable number of
papers so I was expecting a lot of
comparisons against competing techniques
and when looking at the paper and the
supplementary materials boy did I get it
make sure to have a look at the paper it
contains a very exhaustive validation
section which reveals that if we measure
the error of the solution in terms of
human perception it is only slightly
lower quality than the best technique
however this one is 5 times quicker
offering a really nice balance between
quality and performance so what about
the actual numbers for the execution
time for instance up sampling an image
to increase its resolution to twice its
original size takes less than a second
and we can go up to even eight times the
original resolution which also only
takes four and a half seconds the
quality and the execution times indicate
that we are again one step closer to
mainstream super resolution what a time
to be alive
the source code of this project is also
available thanks for watching and for
your generous support now see you next
time